this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning everyone can you hear me
all right
we hear you wonderfully Peter well right
well good to be with you all virtually
today
let's Jump Right In
so these are the topics I'm going to
talk about uh presented as the take-home
messages so I'm not going to read all of
these but that gives you an idea of
where we're going during the next half
an hour and we'll come back to all of
these again at the end
um
just following up on on Jenny's
introduction our Focus today is land
that's not currently in forest and not
currently an agricultural production in
New York state in particular
but of course this applies to many other
parts of the of the U.S as well
so I just want to start with a little
historical perspective about forests in
New York state and this applies to much
of the northeastern USA uh prior to
European settlement most of the area was
forested and that decreased through the
1700s and 1800s
since the since around 1900
Forest area has been increasing again
and that's because the agriculture
much agricultural production has shifted
to the higher productivity soils in the
midwest so
we've had an increase in Forest area in
the last hundred years
so where did that land come from that is
now this this new Forest
well the total Farmland has has
decreased over this time period
but the cropland meaning where we're
growing row crops so the more intensive
agriculture on the best lands we're
using just about the same area as we
have been for quite a long time so the
cropland's been fairly stable but a lot
of the
a lot of the more marginal hilly slope
land has gone out of production
so I just want to talk a little bit
about this this jargon of marginal lands
and and idle lands what do we mean by
these
well idle lands is really just meaning
that it's not in currently in in
commercial uh production of some kind
it's really a wide variety of land cover
meaning what the land looks like so some
of its grasses and shrubs some is is
Young forest or beginning Forest
uh
some of it's used for hunting or other
purposes
it's hard to get a handle on these lands
because they they kind of are the gaps
in in many surveys so if they're not an
agricultural production they're not
really going to get picked up in the
agricultural surveys and if they're not
Forest land uh
even if they might have some young trees
on them they may not be picked up in
Forest surveys
there was a survey in New York state of
land used for horses and it was found to
be more than a million Acres
and many of these Idol lands are are
marginal so that's the next little bit
of jargon to to talk about and here's a
quote from almost 100 years ago that the
word marginal has been used too glibly
as a convenient way to say land that is
Barren rough or has other undesirable
characteristics so often when we talk
about marginal land people think about
kind of the physical aspects of that
land whether it's uh low productivity
soils or slopes
but there's also a strong economic
component and and this term marginal is
really an economic term to say that it's
marginal for
for agricultural or commercial
production for economic activity in
other words the cost to produce
something you may not get that back
there may be no profit at all in in
producing some kinds of crops on these
lands
well that means that what's marginal to
one person or one operation might not be
to another so land that might be
marginal for corn production could be
just fine for wine grapes
so we did an analysis of of how much of
this land might be available for
different purposes such as bioenergy
production or in what we're talking
about today a growing New Forest or
afforestation
so we used a combination of
of the available data so that included
spatial data derived from remote sensing
as well as survey data
about agricultural production
we eliminated small Parcels because we
were thinking about
uh
adding some type of production and we
thought it was more practical to do that
on the larger Parcels of land
we also assumed that not all landowners
would want to use this land for for any
purpose whether it's growing trees
or any other type of harvest
and to jump to the result we came up
with after applying
uh some of these filters about
small Parcels sloping lands as well as
landowner interest we came up with with
an estimate of 1.7 million Acres
so just to be clear there's much more of
this land
out there but we don't think it's likely
that all of it would be used for any
particular purpose
there have been other studies of course
there's there's a lot of assumptions
that go into this so a more recent
analysis found a higher value
uh basically a similar analysis but it's
a question about the Assumption of of
how much of that land might be available
so how do idle lands fit into overall
land use in the state
so here's just a picture uh a pie chart
showing that most of the land in New
York is forested
as others a substantial amount that's
developed
there are wetlands there's Open Water
croplands grasslands
and then this Idol end we're talking
about
is about five percent of the state
and then scrubbling so landed has some
shrubs
in it is about three percent
so what could we do with these lands
well that's our topic for today
uh
so I'm gonna just mention a few
possibilities here we could grow
bioenergy feedstocks and we've done uh
We've published analysis on
the potential for using these lands for
these for this purpose
we could also grow more livestock feed
that could be hay or other forage crops
it could also be increased use of
pasture for livestock
the next talk you're going to hear this
morning is is solar panels and more
generally thinking about renewable
energy production on these lands
and then again just that there are many
other uses for this land Recreation
wildlife habitat Etc
I'm going to be focusing on the
opportunity for growing new forests on
these lands
well the reason we're thinking about uh
growing forests is we can store quite a
bit of carbon so forests as they grow
are removing carbon from the atmosphere
and storing it in growing trees
uh
this is part of a whole what they're
calling here a closed loop of forest
carbon in the atmosphere so we can pull
carbon out of the atmosphere into trees
and then we can use those for energy uh
they can be lost due to fire or disease
or other mortality we can put them into
wood products that may last quite a long
time so we can sequester carbon from the
atmosphere in houses and chairs Etc
so forests can
the reason we focus on on forests for
storing carbon is they really can store
quite a bit
and that's a that's primarily in in
trees but also in soil as well
we heard in the introduction from Jenny
a little bit about uh the New York State
context in terms of the community uh
climate leadership and Community
protection act
um
what I want to focus on here is this
requirement for Net Zero greenhouse gas
emissions by 2050.
so emissions need to be reduced by 85
percent but then also needing to get to
Net Zero and the reason for that is
people who analyze greenhouse gas
mitigation opportunities across all
sectors
uh it's very very hard to get that last
bit of emissions to zero
it gets it's very difficult and very
expensive so that's the the law allows
that last 15 percent
to be achieved by removing carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere
and there is a draft scoping plan of
ways to achieve these goals that's
available for public comment currently
excuse me
so here's just an example of of carbon
sequestration in a typical Northern
hardwood stand in the region so the
black line at the top is the total
carbon uh after the stand starts to grow
so if you started with an old field and
if you planted trees or had trees
naturally growing and you had a healthy
stand
you'd accumulate carbon rapidly for more
than a hundred years and eventually it
would begin to level off
the red line is the next one to the top
and that's the live trees so again just
showing that most of the carbon in the
forest that's growing is in the live
trees themselves
and here's a picture of of what this may
look like
with some young trees growing in a
former agricultural uh
field or pasture
so why haven't Forrest already regrown
on Old farmland
well the reason is
there's a lot of competition there so
the
the grasses and and other vegetation
can suppress the trees and a big issue
is also deer they browse they can browse
a thousand tree seedlings a day and
prevent them that forest from regrowing
foreign
so there are many places we can plant
trees and I just want to briefly mention
a few of them and then Focus back on
these former agricultural lands
so we could plant trees in some in
former agricultural lands and as we're
talking about today there there is
competition for these lands
we could also plant more trees in
developed Urban and Suburban areas
and that can have a lot of benefits uh
it it's also an expensive proposition
and when I'm not going to be focusing on
that today
we can plant trees to increase Forest
stalking which just means increasing the
number of trees so if we have a young
Forest
that
maybe there's heavy deer pressure and
there aren't enough young seedlings if
we could plant some seedlings in that
forest and protect them from Deer we can
increase the growth rate of existing
forests
and again this is an important
opportunity for New York State and other
places uh I just want to mention this uh
briefly even though we're not focusing
on on Forest remaining forests today
we also want to be thinking about
planning native tree species that are
adapted to climate change so we might
want to be planting uh
species and and varieties that are
suitable for the future climate that
we're expecting in coming decades not
necessarily the climate we've had in
previous decades
foreign
so this slide just summarizes some of
the opportunity and the barriers here so
we calculated that
if we planted trees successfully on on
this 1.7 million Acres we could
sequester almost 5 million metric tons
of carbon dioxide equivalent per year
um
in the long run this could also be
producing long-lived Wood Products this
calculation is just for storing carbon
in the growing Forest
there are of course other competing
opportunities we'll be talking about
some of those I'll talk about those a
little bit more uh and then in the next
session we'll be hearing about uh solar
and renewable energy
so what are some of the barriers to this
idea of tree planting well I've
mentioned existing deer pests and
invasive shrubs can prevent forests from
regrowing
this land is also typically owned by
private landowners in small Parcels so
there's a real issue about communicating
with folks sharing the opportunity even
if people are interested it's a big
project to get a lot of small parses of
land uh planted
there's variable soil quality and of
course landowners have many interests
and goals for their land
there are also substantial costs to tree
planting and protecting those seedlings
from deer and competing vegetation
so in summary there's a lot of
possibility here but there are lots of
unknowns and lots of work would be
required to actually have a large tree
planting effort
so I'll just briefly mention other some
some
we can also add trees to current
agricultural land so this is called
agroforestry so mixing in some forestry
production with agriculture so this is
an example of a silvo pasture which
means a silvo for trees and and pasture
for livestock so this is growing black
locust and black walnuts trees
as as crops the black Locus for fence
posts and the Walnut for valuable trees
over a long time period and also
livestock production
so I'm not going to be focusing on this
but I just want to mention that uh there
is substantial potential to add trees to
agricultural land as well as former
agricultural land
additionally we're focusing on planting
trees for sequestering carbon but of
course there are lots of values to
forests and in many cases people may
value some of those other benefits the
forests equally or or more so than the
carbon benefits
this is important to remember if we're
comparing using tree planting as a way
to store carbon
compared to some other efforts so there
are technological efforts to remove
carbon from the atmosphere using
industrial processes
even if those are affordable and
successful they're not going to provide
all of the other benefits provided by a
forest
when we think about carbon sequestration
there are some important criteria so we
want it to be permanent or at least very
long term
climate change is a long-term issue so
we also need solutions that are
long-term so think about that are
treason forests permanent
well I would say probably not but if
they're healthy they can be very
long-term
in areas at least where you don't have
frequent forest fires and things like
that but kind of disturbance
we also want uh carbon sequestration to
be real and additional so we want it to
be on top of what we're doing already
and in this case we want actual
reductions of carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
but what this means is we don't want to
just plant trees in one area and cut
trees down in some other area that's
called leakage and
if that happens there's no real benefit
to the climate at all
and then verifiable we want to make sure
if we're making an effort
to sequester carbon that it we really
are storing carbon an advantage of trees
is they can be measured and we can
pretty accurately estimate how much
carbon is being stored in them
foreign
we want to remember always that there
are other options so we looked at using
this same land base for growing uh as I
mentioned growing
grasses or other materials for bioenergy
feedstocks
we also looked at the possibility
of increased grazing and beef production
on these lands
uh so this next slide is is what's
called technical potential so this would
be if we use this entire land base of
1.7 million acres for these activities
and again there are many reasons why
that would be challenging to to reach
that
technical potential
so we use data from uh from forage
trials so this is a growing uh forage
for livestock in a fairly intensive
manner so using enough fertilizer and
other practices to have high
productivity
and this could be for example for beef
production
so this is showing multiple different
products we could produce
uh on some portions of this land so a
little bit of hayland uh land that's in
uh herbaceous cover uh
so grasses and other small plants and
then shrub lands that's in shrubs
the red bars are beef the black is
ethanol if we use the bioenergy
feedstock to produce a liquid fuel
using it for pellets or the green is for
hay and this is just showing the value
of these products this isn't the
profitability just showing that there
are multiple different products we could
produce from this land
that could potentially have value to
society
foreign but how do owners want to manage
their land
this is a survey from a quite a few
years ago now and there's some ongoing
work with a new survey that should be
ready shortly
but owners of idle land most of them
have no plans to sell the land or to
return it to active agriculture
ten percent do plan to sell their land
within 10 years and only about 10
percent of buyers are expected to be
farmers
so the trend here if this older survey
data is is still uh applies today is
less and less of an emphasis on
agricultural production
a third of this land is managed by
occasional Mowing and a third has has no
management plan at all
okay so we're
we're back to uh to the take-home
messages
uh and then I'll just have a few slides
of uh some some follow-up uh information
so as we've talked about
we've estimated about 1.7 million Acres
of former agricultural land could be
available for multiple purposes
as I mentioned we actually estimated
much more than this more than 3 million
Acres
but we don't think it's feasible to
consider that all of that land would be
mobilized and and used for any specific
uh purpose because people have so many
different interests in what they want to
do with their land
foreign
New York state has a legal Mandate of
net greenhouse gas Net Zero greenhouse
gas emissions
and planting trees is a natural and
proven way to remove carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere so to help to get to that
Net Zero critical opportunity
I did I mentioned cost just briefly and
I'm not focusing on that today but I did
mention that there are substantial costs
to plantain planting trees and
protecting them from deer and competing
vegetation
but if we think about the costs of the
damage from climate change
then the cost of growing trees might be
uh quite affordable as a as a greenhouse
gas mitigation strategy
and planting trees on this 1.7 million
acres of land could sequester almost 5
million metric tons of carbon dioxide
equivalents per year
so this would represent about adding
about 22 percent to the sequestration in
current forests
so it's actually that gives an idea of
how ambitious this strategy would be
however it's that amount is only 12
of of the carbon dioxide removal that
has been estimated to be needed by by
2050 in other words uh
it doesn't get us anywhere near that 15
percent of emissions uh
reductions that
modeling efforts have identified will
probably be be needed
so how could we increase that amount
well
we could plant faster growing trees we
could plant trees on additional lands
uh and we can also increase the growth
rate of existing forests so there are
opportunities to
sequester more than this amount on the
1.7
a million Acres that we identified
on the other hand
there's competition for this land for
recreation livestock grazing hay
production
Etc
so further information about this topic
is available on our our website which is
at the at the bottom of the
of this slide
in particular uh there's a report that
we produce that's that's linked from
there that includes this
this opportunity for afforestation along
with many other key opportunities for
reducing greenhouse gas emissions in
agriculture and and Forest sectors
as I mentioned there's a New York State
climate Action Council draft scoping
plan if you're interested to see uh the
the different ways including
afforestation that are being proposed by
the state to achieve the goals of
and the legal mandates for greenhouse
gas mitigation
uh there
I mentioned a more recent study about uh
reforestation opportunity and one
important thing for some in the audience
this is a national study this U.S
reforestation Hub by The Nature
Conservancy so they produce estimates
not only for New York state but for
every other state in the country
foreign
here's the the literature cited and we
can provide that uh
later for any of you who are interested
and again this will be posted on our
website in about a week uh the recording
of this presentation it'll be available
there
I want to thank uh
the funding sources for this work the
climate and applied forestry Research
Institute and uh USDA Smith Lieber
project
and lastly we have two more
presentations this morning and then May
10th uh as Jennifer mentioned there'll
be a another webinar focusing on on food
waste specifically
thanks very much
thank you Peter I realized in
introducing you I was um
very formal
um
okay so there's some really great
questions
um and I'm gonna go in an asymmetric
order not in the order that they arrived
um and uh Jen just posted a quick poll
in in your window if you could respond
to that so I'm going to take the first
question from Tim thanks Peter great
overview what is the timeline for the
4.9 million metric tons of CO2
equivalents per year is this over a 20
40 80 year timeline time frame do you
have an estimate of the rate of
sequestration which would be lower at
the start and then accelerate
a good question
I'm trying to remember that this was an
average annual value
I believe it was across a 30-year period
uh but I'm not sure of that that average
wouldn't
vary too much going a little bit above
or below a 30-year period
uh as as you and and many others know in
the very long run this sequestration
would slow down so I showed one example
for a maple Beach Birch stand where uh
well after after a hundred years uh
sequestration slows down and in much
older stands sequestration
becomes much slower than than what we're
talking about here
and that's where some
Forest management would be required at
that point to maintain sequestration
rates harvesting material for wood
products
Etc
so I'm just going to quickly follow up
with a question from Tom Giro Peter how
long would it take to get the 4.9
million metric tons of sequestration if
it were all planted in Year One
I don't have an exact answer for that
again this was an average uh
sequestration rate
per year over a long uh you know about a
30-year period so
um
after the stand is planted
um
it's going to take a decade or two to
achieve that kind of rapid growth rate
I'm sorry I don't have a more exact
answer
uh
we did
as an aside we did assume that the
average growth rate of these stands
would be that Maple Beach Birch stand
example that I showed which is based on
measured growth rates uh throughout the
Northeast region for Maple Beach Birch
stands
so if you look back at that growth curve
uh both of these questions can be
answered I think by by looking at that
curve
so Scott fickborne asks
um you mentioned not including smaller
Parcels in your analysis what was the
lower threshold also in the approximate
5 million metric tons per year Max
estimate how many trees per acre were
you using
okay so
um the threshold for small Parcels was
two hectares and again this is an
assumption there's no reason you can't
plant trees on a small parcel
we we eliminated those because we
originally performed this analysis to
look at bioenergy production and we just
thought it was more practical to think
about larger Fields
um
so again there's no technical reason why
why you couldn't do it but if you
imagine mobilizing people and materials
and projects
um
it's going to be easier to mobilize and
conduct those
on larger Parcels than on the smaller
Parcels but again there's no reason why
that technically couldn't be done and
sorry I lost the second question it was
how many trees per acre were you using
in your assumption foreign
so again we assumed that the growth rate
that would be achieved would be the
average growth rate of existing Maple
Beach Birch stands in the Northeast and
I don't have
uh
I don't have a number in mind for what
that stocking rate represents but that
would be the average stocking rate for
those stands throughout the Northeast
of course if you're planting trees even
if you're protecting them they're not
all going to survive so
you know you're going to need to be
planting uh hundreds of of trees
per acre
if you don't have natural regeneration
either helping or providing enough
seedlings
so David K asks one of the alternative
land uses you didn't focus on is
residential development have people been
looking at this in the context of
reforestation barriers and opportunities
a good question I don't know
um
the answer to that I would say
anecdotally
um
the
kind of parcelization you know people
buying second homes or having a five or
ten acre plot of land around
uh a primary home or a secondary home
anecdotally and and you probably know
better than I do David what
you know how common that is throughout
the state and whether those folks who
own a piece of property primarily for
residents are interested in in tree
planting
um
but in short I don't have an an answer
for that question but it is
you're right that's an important
competing use
especially again for uh
if we had high density development
that's a relatively small area of land
but low density sprawl or ex-urban
development can take up quite a bit of
land
so Sam Bosco asks I am wondering if the
presenters analyst here would be
interested in collaborating with
agriforcey specialists in New York to
quantitatively evaluate agroforestry for
food alley cropping civil pasture as
another option for the beneficial use of
marginal land that is also sequestering
carbon
a short answer yes I think this is it uh
uh there aren't any good estimates of
the kind of technical potential for this
and more importantly the the
[Music]
kind of Economic and other practical
potential for integrating more trees uh
into existing Farms
so as you mentioned I use the example of
silvo pasture
but there are many other kinds of
agroforestry and I know you're
interested in in nut trees in particular
uh but yes trees for producing nuts and
fruits and various other products could
be integrated into farms and anytime
we're adding trees we're adding carbon
to the landscape
so Elise Brule asks is there modeling
work linking deer impacts to force
carbon sequestration this work seems
needed to influence the climate action
committee to take deer impacts more
seriously and push for more aggressive
gear management to support forced carbon
sequestration
okay so I the question I heard is is
there analysis of the effect of deer on
Forest regeneration and carbon
sequestration yes there's quite a bit of
that analysis most of it has focused on
Forest growth
but uh that directly translates to
carbon right it's so so if you're having
a healthy growing Forest you're
accumulating carbon and if you don't
have a healthy growing Forest you're
you're not
um
it's very hard to control Deer uh either
through hunting or sterilization this is
not my area but from the from the
research I'm aware of uh the research on
that is it's quite challenging say
through intensive hunting or
sterilization it's really difficult to
control deer enough to allow a healthy
regeneration of forests
fences can be used but those require a
lot of Maintenance especially in
forested areas where trees and branches
fall on them
there's a technique called slash walls
that's been developed by Peter smallage
and Brett ched zoy and is being
implemented in New York and other places
in the Northeast where low value or
non-commercial branches and and tree
material during a harvest you can
basically make up a a wall out of tops
and and some low value wood that keeps
the deer out uh this is ex expensive uh
but it is a has been shown to be highly
effective
in protecting uh regrowing stands from
Deer
okay so I'm now going to
present Charlie canham's questions it's
a long commentary but it's a nice segue
to our next speaker Han solar
um and uh maybe Peter can try to respond
to Rosemary and John in in the chat
afterwards
so Charlie says the Kerry Institute
Solar Shield contains four thousand
square meters of panels in a one hectare
footprint it generated 808 megawatt
hours of electricity in 2021. these
rates are right in line with national
estimates of potential for one gigawatt
production per three acres of solar
footprint
our best estimate of the net
sequestration rates for New York forests
over the next 50 years is 4.2 metrics
tons of CO2 equivalents per hectare that
includes live tree biomass detrital
Dynamics and storage and harvested wood
products and is based on current Harvest
regimes and climate change impacts
New York's electric power production
generates 0.49 metric tons of CO2
equivalents per megawatt hours this is
2020 beta with a total emission of 26.7
million metric tons of CO2 from
54.4 million megawatt hours of fossil
fuel sourced electricity so
1.7 million acres of land could be
expected to offset 10.7 percent at most
of current greenhouse gas emissions of
New York's electricity generation
but those rates would easily take 10 to
20 years to achieve as plantations
accelerated their rates of growth so
10.7 percent is a liberal and
overestimate of sequestration
so
taking just one percent of that 1.7
million Acres that is 17 000 Acres or 6
800 hectares would generate
5.6 million megawatt hours of
electricity or 10.2 percent of fossil
fuel sourced generation so given all the
other values including important
biodiversity values of that 1.7 million
Acres why would you want to plant trees
when using just one percent of the land
could achieve the same net reduction in
greenhouse gases along with elimination
eliminating the other pollutions
associated with fossil fuel
use
so a great question I'll answer this in
brief and then our next talk can answer
it
at more length
um it's not either or
so this is why I focused on uh
the the idea that even if we reduce
emissions as much as we possibly can and
that means maximizing renewable energy
production in the state after we
maximize that production and put all the
panels that we can practically use and
all the windmills we can practically use
there will still be a need to remove
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
so that's what I was focusing on again
it's not an either or question here we
need a lot more Renewables as soon as
possible and I would argue we also want
to look for opportunities to plant trees
in ways that are provide multiple
benefits including carbon sequestration
and just acknowledge you know Charlie
Cannon's an expert in this area so uh
check out all the numbers he's
presenting are based on rigorous
research and they're well worth checking
out
thank you so much Peter that was great
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu